good day and welcome i'm jack van horn from the
university of virginia and please allow me to
welcome you to this edition of our 2020 2021
foundations of biomedical data science seminar
series it is my honor to welcome our speaker
today dr andrei irimia who is assistant professor
at the usc leonard davis school of gerontology
at the university of southern california
he completed his bachelor's degree in computer
science and mathematics from lipscomb university
in 2002 followed by a master's degree in computer
science from vanderbilt university in 2004
and an ms and phd in biophysics from vanderbilt
in 2007 he's completed post-doctoral fellowships
at uh in brain mapping and neurophysiology at uc
san diego as well as in multimodal neuroimaging
at ucla and since um since that time he's been
based now at uh the both the ucla and at the
university of southern california dr irmia is a
computational neuroscientist neuro gerontologist
biomedical engineering researcher and biophysicist
with interest covering a broad range of topics in
neural injury degeneration plasticity and repair
his research utilizes computational biological
approaches and multimodal imaging to study how
the brain connectivity alterations caused by
insults to the brain contributes to connectome
reorganization to cognitive degeneration and
to recovery he's published extensively on mr
physics anatomic structural theory bioengineering
as well as inverse localization and human brain
imaging a key component of this research is
trying to understand the relationship between
brain injury amyloid angiopathy dementia and
how these conditions interact with one another
this focus includes vascular dimensions of neural
degeneration and cognitive decline as well as
the interaction between cardiovascular health
and brain atrophy he's particularly interested in
unique populations with a typical aging profiles
uh similar to what we are going to hear about
today his work is funded through grants from
the national institutes of health as well as
from the department of defense and his lecture
today is entitled brain aging inflammation
and cardiovascular health insights from an
indigenous pre-industrial society in south america
as always we are streaming this lecture live and
for recording via youtube and if you are watching
via youtube uh thank you so much for joining us
we'd also like to invite our specially selected
2021 biomedical data science innovation lab
participants to submit any questions that they
have for dr ermey via the chat feature in their
zoom sessions i will synthesize these questions
and ask them on your behalf during the last 10
minutes or so of dr aramia's lecture and with that
welcome andrei we are really looking forward to
your lecture good morning jack thank you very much
for that very kind introduction and uh thank you
for having me here i'd like to thank you and
the organizers for inviting me to speak uh at
this year's innovation lab um and the topic of my
talk today lies at the intersection of brain aging
neuroinflammation vascular disease and dementia
in industrialized societies like our own
it turns out that dementia and vascular disease
are a major cause of death and as you can see on
this slide if we tally up the causes of death
worldwide we find that nearly a third of them
are accounted for by vascular disease whether
cerebral vascular or cardiovascular disease
and alzheimer's disease and of the top 10
causes of death that are known ad is the
only one which cannot be prevented or cured
so obviously we have a an important mission
to understand how alzheimer's disease interacts
with with the vascular components of brain
function and structure and there has been a lot of
research and interest on relating cerebrovascular
disease to cardiovascular disease and to on
in understanding how these two facets of brain
health are related to cognitive impairment and how
they can lead to alzheimer's disease down the road
one interesting aspect about alzheimer's
disease is that there is an increasing amount of
interest in the question as to how our modern
lifestyles might affect dementia risk so we
do not live the lives that our ancestors did we
have a very different industrialized society we
most humans live in urbanized environments
and it's estimated that the percentage of
individuals living in urban areas will increase
dramatically throughout the 21st century
and with urbanized environments and modern
lifestyles from uh air pollution a sedentary
lifestyle unhealthy diets especially
in western societies and it is known
that these factors affect cardiovascular health
and perhaps even brain health and there's been
gathering evidence to suggest this and
what prospective studies have found
is that there are significant associations
between alzheimer's disease hypertension
and obesity and it would be very interesting to
know whether alzheimer's disease is a byproduct
of modern environments which contain these
environmental factors that are damaging
to health they're damaging to uh brain health
and the cardiovascular system so to answer that
question we have to turn to populations that
live traditional pre-industrial lifestyles
uh that are similar to those experienced in human
prehistory now unfortunately there are very few
uh populations uh that are like that left in the
world today there are very few uh groups of people
that have not been affected by uh the modern uh
industrial by the industrial revolution first
of all and by the um technological advances
that occurred after that in the past several
centuries uh there are very few people still
left that live traditional lifestyles that are
similar to those experienced by
humans during prehistory and however
there is one at least one such group that is very
interesting especially for that reason and we
have been studying that group for uh quite a while
this is the chimane people of the bolivian amazon
so in the low land regions of the amazon as you
can see here in this square highlights the area of
bolivia where the chimane people live uh have this
industry a pre-industrial lifestyle uh that they
have preserved to a remarkable extent uh this is
a population of about 16 000 people who practice
a traditional style of agriculture there are
hunter-gatherers and horticulturalists they live
in the bolivian amazon basin and they have been
studied by u.s researchers for over 20 years and
i have been part of this collaboration for the
past five years and i would like to share with
you today some of the insights that we
have gained from the chimanei regarding
cardiovascular health inflammation and how these
factors affect brain aging and potentially the
risk for dementia so the chimanei uh health and
lifestyle project got started uh over 20 years ago
and its aim is to study the chimane people of
bolivia the chimane live a subsistence lifestyle
they do not have access to uh electricity modern
or any of the modern the staples of modern society
that we are used to they live in a very remote and
inaccessible region of the bolivian amazon basin
it is they live in traditional villages
they obtain their food either by hunting
uh using bows and arrows they practice
uh traditional forms of fishing and
farming and they carve two rogues as you can
see uh on this slide out of uh large trunks of
trees that live in uh that are growing the
uh amazon they have relatively quite little
um interaction with modern society
because they they are so remote from
um from our way of life uh geographically and and
their uh region of the world is very inaccessible
so they have been largely unaffected by all the
changes in diet uh and and other factors that have
um affected the humans for uh for
hundreds of years now um they are also
not subject to uh the same uh air pollution that
many uh individuals in in western countries uh
are uh subjected to and so they live uh in a
very uh pristine area of the world and their
uh specific case uh is a very unique one and
so they're they're very much worthy of our
attention um and investigation the chimane
diet consists about 17 of protein of which
about 10 percent uh consists of game about
seven percent consists of fish uh they eat
uh mostly lean meat and fish uh that come from
animals and fish that live in the area of the
world where they live so there are peccaries uh
tapirs capybaras uh monkeys uh in that area of uh
of the forest and uh piranha fish as you can see
catfish uh are a big staple of their of their diet
uh they also eat a lot of fruits and vegetables
that grow in their uh uh naturally in their in
their region uh and they practice a traditional
form of agriculture they grow some corn and
a few other vegetables and and plants that
are raised that are grown in a traditional way
now the chimane health and lifestyle project is
a international consortium with consisting of
scientists from a wide variety of
disciplines gerontologists like myself
neuroimaging experts anthropologists
epidemiologists biologists from
a number of uh universities in the us in in
europe and elsewhere as well as from south america
and our aim is to study the chimane people
because we are interested in gaining insights
that can help us to understand the vascular the
causes of vascular disease and neurovascular and
cardiovascular disease and dementia and i will
tell you in this talk why the chimane are so
interesting from this particular standpoint uh
what's shown in this picture is the ct scanner
that's located in the city of trinidad bolivia
which is the closest uh city with an imaging
facility uh uh and that's most proximal to the
area of the world where where the chimane lives
uh there are in and in the past uh 10 15
years the collaboration has scanned over
uh 15 to 1800 to many adults aged 40 or over
who have been provided with transportation from
their villages to the city of trinidad uh which is
a small city of about 30 30 000 people located uh
about eight hours drive from the closest place
where the chimanei can be provided for uh trans
land transportation um and um the
city has a city scanning facility
where the chimanei are can be scanned they
receive both chest ct scans and head scans
the chest scans are used to quantify coronary
artery calcium or cag and from head scans we
can quantify brain volume as i will explain later
we also have extensive clinical and laboratory
data that have been acquired uh from the chumanne
there are genetic data uh bio blood biomarkers of
inflammation uh and and other um quantities
that can be extracted from blood um and this
study has from the its very inception uh had the
irb approval of all the institutions in the u.s
that are involved uh there's about six or seven
of them as well as from the bolivian government
and we have local approval from the chimane
traditional councils from the villages and from
the individuals themselves who participate in this
collaboration uh and and here you can see uh uh on
the left this is a picture of myself a few years
ago uh in the area where the chimane lives we the
group travels there every year for campaigns to
acquire data from um from the chimane lately we
haven't been able to do so because of the pandemic
but we uh anticipate resuming our work uh there uh
after that and here in the middle you can see the
at the bottom you can see the amazon basin uh with
all its tributaries and the area shown with the
circle is the area where uh the chumanai live so
they live in the lowlands of bolivia uh relatively
low altitude and this is a sample ct scan
chest ct scan from uh the from a sample chimane
participant so in terms of lifestyle the shimane
have a lifestyle quite different from our own as
you might expect their levels of daily exercise
are much higher than in western societies so in
the u.s the mean number of average uh number of
steps per day taken by a u.s individual is a bit
over five or six thousand steps in uh the chimanei
culture uh since they're so involved in um fishing
uh agriculture uh they're very involved in in with
their environment uh and obtaining uh their uh
necessities from the surrounding environment
they have um they're much more physically
active so uh the average uh chimane female um
registers about 16 000 uh steps per day uh and
they're a little bit uh they walk a little maybe
just a little under the uh number of a number of
steps that the chibane males take because they're
molly more involved in cooking taking care
of children in the villages whereas the males
walk more because they they're more involved in
fishing and in hunting and so forth and every
family has to provide for itself uh so the males
of the family often go uh every day or every other
day on on they go hunting or fishing and uh the
the females uh are more involved with with cooking
and taking care of the children in in the villages
uh and when we look by age category and as you
can see here uh we see that um there is also a
sustained um level of daily physical exercise
throughout the lifespan of the chimanei so even
individuals as you can see here on the right who
are in their uh 60s or older than their 60s still
maintain a high level of daily physical exercise
and this is this is uh possibly quite significant
for uh some of the unusual demographics and
epidemiological findings that that
have been reported in the chimane
now there has been quite a bit of study on how
physical activity predicts mortality and we
know that there is a direct relationship between
physical activity and decreases in in all-cause
mortality this is from a study published almost 10
years ago in the lancet in a taiwanese population
and we if we look at um on the x-axis
we have activity levels from inactive to
very active and on the y-axis we have the hazard
ratio for various causes of mortality and for
all causes we see that there's a fairly linear
relationship where physical exercise is protective
against all-cause mortality it is also protective
against cancer uh cardiovascular disease
and and diabetes so so this has been established
uh it's been known for a long time and uh as you
might expect uh physical exercise is probably uh
going to affect the the chimanei uh quite a bit
now uh from the same study there's it's also
been seen that uh the mortality reduction
associated with exercise with increasing
levels of exercise uh is dependent on the
intensity of physical exercise so the
most vigorous type of exercise leads to
a greater reduction in mortality with despite
engaging in such exercise for shorter periods
of time so for example we can achieve
about a 45 reduction in all-cause mortality
with 50 minutes of vigorous daily physical
exercise but uh with a more moderate exercise more
time more daily exercises is needed to achieve
comparable levels of mortality reduction
uh so in terms of dietary intake the team has
analyzed uh the type of money and what has been
found is that uh their diet differs quite
a bit from the traditional american diet uh
carbohydrates in the u.s form about an average 50
percent of the american diet in the chimane they
they're about two-thirds of their diet what's
very interesting is that whereas in the u.s
uh fat intake is about uh 34 uh total including
about 11 saturated fats and two or three percent
trans fats in the chimanei uh there's only about
16 fat intake and only five percent or so um
of the fat intake is associated with um
saturated fats and the amount of trans fats
that the chamomile consume are is
is really negligible so there is a
basically a big distinction related to fat intake
and uh respectively and uh there's about half as
much uh of the percentage of of uh the diets uh
seen in the chimane is consists of fat compared
to the united states so 16 versus 34 percent and
the amount of protein intake is quite comparable
uh now there is something a very
interesting twist to this story because
even though the chimane walk a lot they get
in a lot of physical exercise they seem to be
eating a healthier diet than the average
american they also have very high levels
of chronic inflammation because they
do not have access to traditional
to modern medicine so there is there
also there's a high uh prevalence of
respiratory inflammatory diseases uh tuberculosis
chronic respiratory infections uh the chemo
the average qmanet has about four to
six uh intestinal parasite infections
so there's uh throughout their life
they experience a very high systemic
inflammatory load and inflammation is known to
be associated with cardiovascular disease risk
and here are several uh two comparisons that
are very illuminating so looking at a c-reactive
protein which as some of you may know is a
biomarker of inflammation in the chicken a
we see that there is as a function of age there
are very quite high levels of crp in the blood
in circulating crp whereas in the united states
levels are quite a bit lower significantly lower
similarly if we look at interleukin-6 another
biomarker of inflammation we see substantial
differences significant differences between
the chimanei who have very high levels of il-6
measured in picograms per milliliter
so this is in the blood compared to
the united states where levels are a lot lower
so so this is interesting because uh despite
the benefits uh to the humane lifestyle that
i already highlighted there is also this uh
twist in the story related to inflammation and
the inflammatory biomarkers then the chronic
inflammation that the chimane exhibit would lead
us to posit that there should be detrimental
effects on health and this is uh one of the key
reasons that germany are so interesting to um to
study if we look at blood pressure and cholesterol
in the chimane we see a different story so
the average uh systolic blood pressure is lower
on average in the chimane so the lower trace here
on the bottom compared to the united states at all
ages and the difference increases with age as well
so the largest differences are seen in those over
60 and the levels of cholesterol of the chimanei
are significantly significantly lower than in the
united states where which are where the line above
plots the the average levels by age so on the one
hand they have very good systolic blood pressure
good cholesterol levels um but on the other
hand they have very high implant inflammation
so the question is how does all that play out in
terms of their cardiovascular and brain health so
uh in addition to that they do not smoke or there
is minimal tobacco smoking and together all these
factors seem to lead to some very good lifetime
biomarkers the low density liquid protein so the
bad cholesterol lifetime measure is
about 70 milligrams per deciliter which
is quite good on average the blood pressure their
blood pressure is about 116 or 73 uh millimeters
mercury and so uh so these are pretty good figures
uh their fasting blood sugar is quite good and
their average bmi is uh is uh quite reasonable and
so these um factors we have posited uh may lead to
minimal coronary artery calcium throughout life
which has been quantified from the ct scans that
were acquired in bolivia and this is uh uh only
one part of the story uh the other one is that uh
although they have high infectious loads high
inflammation parasite infections as i said
and despite having a very much shortened lifespan
so about 54 years at birth partly or mostly due to
this chronic high inflammatory state uh related
disorders that uh make uh often causes their
deaths so they have lower life expectation they
also have uh delayed atherosclerosis progression
so this is the cat score by age on top is what we
have in the united states so the the x-axis is age
the y-axis is the population percentile and
the z-axis is the cat score and we see that in
in the united states uh shown here above we
have quite a bit of check even by by age 55 and
the levels of cac increased dramatically as a
function of population percentile whereas in
the chimane shown here at the bottom they
have very little coronary artery calcium
throughout their lives and there's only just
minute increases with age and uh and cac is a
correlate of atherosclerosis progression so one
what this reflects is that the chimanei have
very little heart disease they
have a very low incidence of
cardiac infarctions um they have low hyper
low prevalence of hyperlipidemia hypertension
very few cases of heart disease
as i said very few cases of stroke
relatively speaking um and uh possibly uh this
is due to uh their levels of physical activity
and diet but very interestingly despite the very
low very high inflammation that they have they
have very low incidence of dementia and um there
was a paper published by our collaboration in
2017 in the lancet uh where it was reported
that the chimane exhibit the lowest levels
of coronary atherosclerosis ever recorded
or known to science in any human population
and what this study in the chimane demonstrated
was that even preclinical coronary artery disease
can be avoided in most people by achieving low bad
cholesterol a healthy blood pressure low glucose
in the healthy range a healthy bmi very little
tobacco use and a considerable amount of daily
physical activity despite again the presence
of very high levels of chronic inflammation
related to respiratory tract infections and
what this study by kaplan at al in the lancet uh
posited is that in comparison to existing evidence
the chimane of south america have the lowest
prevalence of coronary atherosclerosis despite
the high impact of inflammatory burdens and
is very important for what i will show you
next uh so based on this data we hypothesize
um several things on how brain atrophy might
be related to the levels of inflammation in
the chimane so we know that brain atrophy rates
are associated with vascular disease with high
cholesterol diabetes hypertension all of which are
very widespread in modern industrialized countries
and we know that low cardiovascular risk
is associated with slower brain atrophy
we also know that systemic inflammation
involving the biomarkers i already described
predicts greater brain activity so in
the chimane we have they have low cvd
risk so we might predict slower brain
atrophy but because of the high inflammation
systemically we might predict greater brain
atrophy so the first hypothesis we formulated was
that the populations with lower prevalence of
cbd risk factors should uh exhibit slower brain
atrophy and lower risk of associated cognitive
decline in dementia but based on the inflammatory
biomarkers we hypothesize something that
predicts the opposite namely that high
inflammatory load should lead to faster brain
atrophy so let's see how that played out so to
test that hypothesis we had to develop a uh set of
algorithms for for segmenting uh the brain and its
uh uh components from computed tomography because
mri is not available in that part of the world
it's already very difficult to get ct scans
from these participants it would be very
logistically challenging to get mri scans
from the chimane and because the the closest
city to them only has a ct scanner
so my group has had to develop a
segmentation algorithm to
quantify brain volume from ct
so although mri is is uh more suitable density for
for brain mapping uh especially for quantitative
brain morphology there has been growing ct
used throughout the world especially in the
developed world and for that reason there's
been renewed interest in head ct segmentation
and ct is also more suitable in cases where mri
is unavailable like ours where it's unfeasible
where it's counter indicated for individuals
who cannot get mri scans due to pacemakers and
so forth or if it's too costly like in many
cases in the developing world or even in the
developed world and mri segmentation tools as
many of you known are already technically mature
but there's been very little work on ct brain
segmentation and this is the one gap in the
technical literature that we have uh aimed to
fill and um mri methods as we have demonstrated
are actually quite amenable
to adaptation through to ct
so we have developed a ct-based brain tissue
classification algorithm uh where we segment the
outer layers so the scalp uh the cranium which is
very nicely segmented from ct as you might expect
and then once we get to the soft tissue we
have developed a way to separate the gray
matter from the white matter from the css from
ct scans here is an example for one subject
and here's the you can see the ventricular system
which uh is actually pretty well delineated you
can even see the inter thalamic addition here a
little bit uh you can see the lateral ventricles
the third ventricle and this method uses a an
atlas based probabilistic labeling tool which
is actually quite standard in the mri literature
and has been used for a long time and we assign
each voxel in in each ct scanned to one of three
classes either gray matter white matter in css
and we have validated this tool in subjects
in the us who received both mri nct scans for
various clinical purposes and we took mri as being
the gold standard and uh and acquired also cts
and segmented their the the brain from q1 mri
using free surfer software and then used the ct
scans acquired from the same subjects to
classify white matter gray matter in csf
to calculate intracranial volume and to estimate
the relative errors in segmentation accuracy uh
taking mri as the gold standard and this
was published last year in frontiers in
neuroinformatics and what we found is that using
the dice coefficient which is a very common metric
for this kind of comparisons but also the the
hausdorff distance which is a more sophisticated
we found that the volume estimation errors
uh for white matter in gray matter uh
were are actually quite reasonable so we were
able to calibrate our segmentation method based
on mri to achieve zero percent average estimation
error for both gray matter white matter and csf
with a standard with an error range of about five
percent so that's two two standard deviations
uh above and below the mean error
uh five percent for white matter
four percent for gray matter
and about three percent for csf
and you can see here the comparison between
the segmented brain and csf ventricular system
uh in mri versus ct uh mri as you can imagine has
a better ability to resolve the gyral structure
but ct isn't too bad at all in terms of
finding the total brain volume which is what
we were interested in and it also does a pretty
good job of of identifying the ventricular system
so we quantified this uh extensively we didn't
find any bias in volume estimation errors or
any of these measures that we used uh they
all had a approximately normal distribution
and this was also the case for both dice
coefficients and house storage distances
uh and to compare the chimanei to westerners we
undertook a meta-analysis of 20 years worth of
mri literature uh summarizing data over almost
10 000 typically aging adults this paper was
recently published online in neuroinformatics
and we mapped the trajectories of brain
volume gray matter white matter and css in this
meta-analytic sample meta-analyzed sample from um
from the us and europe as well as uh japan and
a few other places uh all all of these being
industrialized populations and we traced the
trajectories of these brain measures as a function
of age after normalization by intracranial volume
to remove that compound so based on those results
we compared the chimanei rates of cross-sectional
decrease in brain volume with those observed in
the u.s and other industrialized countries and
what we found is that after controlling for sex
uh there is a cross-sectional decrease in brain
volume of about 2.2 percent per decade in the
chimane compared to about 6.5 percent per decade
in the u.s and so this is several times a lower uh
rate of atrocity in the chimane than in the united
states suggesting that the rate of brain aging
and potentially the rate uh the
risk for cognitive impairment
and dementia are modulated uh to a substantial
extent by cardiovascular disease incidents because
the chimanei again have very low cardiovascular
disease so what are the uh conclusions and
significance of this uh well first of all the
chimanei lose brain volume quite modestly with age
which is consistent with a low
burden of cardiovascular disease
and because cardiovascular health is associated
with brain atrophy it is very possible that this
low risk of cardiovascular burden which is
potentially mediated by high levels of exercise
by a diet low in trans fats and saturated fats may
have a highly protective effect upon brain health
and very importantly this suggests that the brain
atrophy can be reduced substantially by lifestyles
associated with such low cardiovascular
disease risk even in the presence of very
high inflammation and what's very important about
this particular study in the chimae is that it
is it provides unique evidence in humans that the
effects of systemic inflammation that's very high
can be counteracted by healthy diet and exercise
and that is the key uh reason that the chimanei
from the perspective of of brain health are such
a unique um and very important population because
normally in the western societies we have
we might have high level high percentages of
sedentary lifestyle we have air pollution but
also because of modern medicine we also have
relatively lower inflammation than in the chimane
but the chimanei have very high inflammation
while having high levels of physical activity
and a healthier diet so this is a very unique
environment a very unique setting to test this
hypothesis of whether exercise and diet can have a
a protective effect on brain health even
in the presence of systemic inflammation
which is uh which is a problem uh not only the
chimane but also in western societies as well
so this also has implications for prevention it
suggests that a diet of very lean wild game and
fish is probably beneficial for health for brain
health and cardiovascular health and it's probably
it indicates that among the chumane one can
avoid coronary atherosclerosis by uh by um
doing a lot of exercise and consuming very
low doses of saturated uh and trans fats and
a key quote from the original publication is that
urbanization and the elimination of a subsistence
diet and lifestyle as uh seen in modern societies
might represent a novel risk factors for coronary
artery disease so in conclusion it's very
possible that at least some of the increases
in coronary artery disease in diabetes in uh
dementia cognitive impairment that we see today
in our societies are possibly due to the fact that
um we live in this industrialized highly urbanized
environment with pollution where we uh where
many people live a sedentary lifestyle and uh
have unhealthy diets so in conclusion i would
like to thank everyone who has been part of
this this is a huge collaboration spanning
several lots of institutions many countries
it's a very interdisciplinary team i'd like
to thank everyone at usc who is part of this
as well as at all the other locations in bolivia
in the united states in europe and elsewhere
i'd like to thank my mentor tak tak finch here
in usc in gerontology and uh margie gatz who have
uh uh with whom i've been collaborating
on this project for the past five years
and uh thank you very much for your interest
and attention uh thank you jack for inviting me
and thank you i'd like to thank the organizers
and the nih for organizing the series and this
innovation lab i'd like to thank the chumane
health and lifestyle project team and the national
institutes of health particularly the national
institute on aging which uh has funded this uh
work under uh an rs1 grant uh and um here at
the bottom uh is a picture of me in uh during
our last trip to bolivia and here standing next to
me is the the president of the chumane so this is
i have to say the the first president that i've
that i've ever met so uh this picture was a very
nice uh and uh uh unique opportunity for me so uh
thank you very much uh for your attention and uh i
would love to hear any questions you might have uh
andrei that was a fantastic talk thank you so much
for for sharing that with us really intriguing
uh uh kind of journey that you took as well as
hearing about the um the the issues that present
themselves to the germany people and just but how
their lifestyle seems to kind of uh be protective
for brain health i like the picture at the end
because you're literally rubbing elbows with world
leaders in order to conduct this this study is
pretty good um one of the the a couple of
questions which are kind of rolled in but it
was also a question i had um about this as well is
that physical exercise in particular has been um
associated with all manner of protective brain
health or as protective for brain health and
this cons i'm aware of studies in parkinson's
disease huntington's disease multiple sclerosis
alzheimer's disease and all as well as just
general psychiatric health and i'm curious if
the chumani people show reduced rates of these
diseases disorders and dysfunctions as well
and if you can comment on that yes
so they show extremely low rate
of uh cognitive impairment very very low rates of
dementia uh several many in fact more than i think
more than an order of magnitude lower than in the
united states also much lower rates of diabetes
as far as parkinson's disease so we are we have
the team has been acquiring cognitive assessments
of uh of the chimane and that data is still under
analysis so so we haven't um distinguished between
dementia and general and alzheimer's in particular
partly because we don't have pet available but uh
there's very lit very few
very low rate of parkinsonism
and uh it seems that even the cases that
just based on preliminary data even the the
cases of dementia that do occur seem to have
a a rather uh unique presentation which is
uh somewhat different from from the presentation
of dementia in industrialized nations
and as far as the mental health uh i think
i have to say i i'm not completely sure
i think that but i do believe that the profile
and prevalence are also quite different from
western society interesting um one thing i was
curious about as you were talking about the
just the level of participation and i realized
there's some you know logistical challenges
of getting um your your subjects to um to the
to where the scanner is located and what not um
what do the what did the tumor they get out
of it right so they're participating in this
dude what's the benefit to them uh what motivates
them to want to participate in studies like this
yes uh the team has been uh very
involved with the chumane for 20 years
the team has developed a very good
working relationship with them
they every time they come over to trinidad for
the scans for these research scans they also
get physical exams and treatment for
whatever medical conditions they might have
they also receive some supplies that is useful
to them in their day-to-day life so they they do
have some artisanal
well they so so there is some uh they knit they
sew so there's various forms of uh uh ways that
we that the team can assist the the chimane while
preserving their way of life so this so there's uh
supplies like that that are provided so there's
various ways like that but i think the the
primary incentive is um is the fact that they they
receive some medical uh attention and treatment
and follow-up as a result of this project
right and are you getting full genome sequences
with uh these um with the tumor name as well there
is uh i know that so i'm not the genome data we're
just starting to look at in more detail and uh we
are getting i think i think it is uh full genome
sequencing uh if uh and uh there is definitely
uh genotyping get a very large number of snips
uh if if full genome sequencing is not done and
do do the journey suffer from any particular
prevalence of genetic disorders uh that does
not seem to be the case uh but again we have not
analyzed uh the genetic data in very much
detail yet one interesting uh potential
finding that's very preliminary is that
their sequencing has confirmed that they are
quite genetically distant from so there's been
very little admixture between them and surrounding
indigenous populations um and there's there's
also been little uh genetic admixture with the uh
that is of uh with individuals of european
descent so there's all so there's less than
less than 10 or maybe five or even less are have
any uh genetic contributions from um from uh from
previous uh interaction with european europeans
or persons with of european descent fantastic um
what about uh are are there any implications
from what you're learning about from the germany
that can directly affect us here in the u.s and
in you know kind of more modern societies around
the world that you know you kind of mentioned
healthy eating and whatnot um on the other hand
i've probably been not eating healthy for oh 50
years or so is it too late for me unlike the two
money who presumably spent their lifetime doing
it um and get to get the benefits of it is it is
it something that one can arrest any downward
slide into dementia uh yes so definitely even
interventions at a later age can be beneficial
uh for example and this is not based on data
that i have shown but uh there's there's a lot
of interest now in epigenetic clocks for example
in uh methylation clocks that uh quantify the
extent of dna methylation and allow us to estimate
biological age of tissues of individuals
based on the extent of dna methylation and
and what what some of those studies
have shown is that the changes in
in lifestyle can lead to a lower rate of
dna methylation which translates into a
slowing down of the aging process in various uh
various tissues and and cell cell type lineages
so so that's but that's coming from outside
this particular work uh from the chimanei
uh what we do know is that uh what we have
found is that um despite the fact that in
the united states and in other western societies
we have very high rates of inflammation chronic
inflammation especially at the older ages because
of diet or air pollution or a sedentary lifestyle
even and even causes of other inflammation
that so that cannot necessarily be removed
so for example air pollution uh for many people
is not a factor that can be easily addressed
the the changes in the diet and changes in um
in diet in exercise can tremendously assist
with creating a protective effect against the in
pro-inflammatory uh factors that are damaging
to health and i think that's the one of the key
uh reasons that the chimane are so interesting to
study is because this is a very unique population
where on the one hand you have high exercise uh
very relatively healthier diet but on the other
hand also a very high inflammatory load
and yet the brain atrophy and the brain
shrinking profiles as a function of age
are very much slower than in in the united
states so that seems to indicate that there is
some major protective effect associated with
exercise and diet and to the extent that
these relationships are causal in the chimanei
that can also uh prevent and and lower
the rates of cognitive decline in dementia
what are the next studies that one hopes to
do with uh the trumane and uh that can help
kind of answer some of the outstanding
questions that you have left
uh so for the moment the uh the star the our
campaigns are have been paused because of the
pandemic interestingly enough um although
the the covet virus has reached bolivia and
and trinidad and the chimane villages uh uh
very very there have been very very few deaths
among the chumane from the kovitz virus
which is again very surprising because
they have a very high inflammatory load
which should translate into a high risk
but they seem and this is something we're studying
now we only have some epidemiological data that's
very preliminary at the moment but it's going
to be very interesting to look at why um the
uh the percentage of of covid survivors uh is
so high relative to the rates of infection and
also why the most of the symptoms in uh those
who do get coveted um are so much milder than
than in countries like our own and in europe so
that's something that we have received funding
from the nih to study uh soon as soon as we can
resume our campaigns we also plan to uh restand
the chimanei their brains to turn this into a
longitudinal study rather than a cross-sectional
study so we're interested now in in quantifying
brain aging in a longitudinal design and looking
at all the other inflammatory factors and and
other variables of interest in the longitudinal
settings uh so that's gonna be a major effort
going forward uh and and possibly uh we could
even look at uh some methylation clocks and uh
uh and look at the changes in the rate of a of
biological aging and and so um that i imagine
that's going to keep us quite busy for the next
five or five to ten years well it's a fascinating
study it's a really fantastic opportunity to
understand how brain aging affects this unique
population and kind of the implications that that
and their lifestyle has for our own um fantastic
talk thank you so much dr hermia for sharing that
with us um with that i think we're uh kind of
at our time i want to thank dr eramia from the
university of southern california for sharing his
work with us i want to thank uh all the people
who uh joined us today both on our innovation lab
participants on zoom and everybody out on youtube
with that thank you very much and thank you
once again dr aramia thank you for having me